- [Narrator] On the outside, this chapel
looks like a normal cathedral.
But on the inside, it's a gilded triumph
to the Catholic faith.
Welcome to the Capilla del Rosario.
The Capilla del Rosario, or Rosary Chapel,
is found inside the
Church of Santo Domingo
in Puebla, Mexico.
It was built in the 17th century
between 1650 and 1690
and was the first chapel in Mexico
dedicated to Our Lady of the Rosary,
or the Virgin Mary.
The chapel, with it's gold
leaf and ornate details,
has been considered the
eighth wonder of the world.
In 1979, Pope John Paul II
called the Rosary Chapel
a reliquary of America.
A shining example of Mexican
baroque architecture,
the chapel has ornate
sculptures, oil paintings,
statues, and moldings covered
in 23 karat gold leaf.
The centerpiece of the
sanctuary is an altar
dedicated to the Virgin Mary.
Even with enough gold to
fill a secure bank safe,
the church regularly holds
mass and other services
for worshipers.
Anyone, religious or not, can appreciate
the golden glow of the
Capilla del Rosario.